it's a lot of Platinum's my name is Zed
and these are some of my iconic songs I
got interested in making music just
because both of my parents make music I
think when I was like four or five is
when I started writing music and my
parents we run keyboards
and then they would record us write our
songs and perform them so I think our
first recordings are from when I was
four or five and my brother was seven or
eight when we started writing our own
songs when I was growing up we didn't
really have much so when we got a
keyboard that is what we had and my
parents would work all day and my
brother and I would just sit and and
write music and record music clarity is
definitely a song that shaped my career
a lot I would say it kind of established
me as an electronic dance music artist
that puts a lot of focus on vocals and
emotions and lyrics I was working on a
song called lost at sea which is also a
song on my album and I asked Matthew
koma to write a vocal for it it was way
too emotional for the track that loss at
sea was and the track law said sea
wasn't really giving the vocal what it
needs so I told Matthew I'm gonna write
a song for that vocal I'm not gonna use
it on this but I'm gonna do something
with it later then I randomly through
just the acapella because it's the same
BPM and happened to be in the same key
just threw that on top of the clarity
instrumental I was like this is really
good this is really strong and just I
had goosebumps and I felt something
special so originally Matthew was the
vocal on clarity but the highest note
and the song was out of his range I was
just going to pitch the note up because
I think it's fine but I know that he was
really adamant about not pitching his
voice I mean the song is really high for
a guy this thing that sounds crazy
anyway
[Music]
so we went through a couple singers and
that wasn't happy and we were getting
close to the point where I had to leave
the track off the album just because I
had my deadline and my manager just was
showing me some vocalists and I heard
Fox and I was like wait this could be
awesome
Saigon's despite the Scott call with her
and kind of talked through what I want
and I want the song sung she was in
England she recorded the next day send
it back and then clarity ended up being
on the album
[Music]
I think spectrum was the first song
Matthew koma and I worked on together so
I was in the studio and I already kind
of wrote ten ideas for a track which is
basically an album so it's kind of like
well I might as well do something so I
started writing a song and I remember my
idea in that little post drop section
was to put as many sounds together as I
could different sounds different samples
and see if I could create something
smart out of that just getting those
sounds together took a really really
long time but since I had so much time
and I was waiting I was like I might as
well spent that time and hit something
with it
with spectrum I was just playing chords
and then I got into like the first four
or five six chords of the progression
spectrum until it loops around is kind
of a lot of chords and I don't know if
there's ever been a song with the exact
same chord progression as spectrum which
is really hard to do
[Music]
so I just did the piano part I record
that and then as I record everything I'm
playing there's the mini essentially
gives you the notes that you played so I
can take those notes into the computer
and then start applying sounds to it so
I just did that and made the whole
instrumental and then I needed a vocal
and then I had Matt come in to the
studio and we started writing I went to
the bathroom for two minutes and and I
had that like something like that but
what we were working on that we couldn't
really figure out as I wait this is
great and I came back and was like Matt
this and this and that and then we
tweaked it and then Matt wrote the
lyrics and then the spectrum was born
Dave the night was kind of the follow-up
single to clarity and I've always been a
huge bear more fan I really wanted to
work with Haley and I think before
clarity it was just so hard for me to
find anybody that would be willing to
work on me because people always thought
DJ's are DJs and they're not musicians
that was the stigma Haley was somebody
who thought that I'm more than just a DJ
and gave it a shot and sang the song and
it was a huge honor in big moment for me
personally because I'm such a big fan so
to get her in a song this was a really
really great moment for me
[Music]
so I made four songs of which beauty and
a beat was the fourth one and I had
Justin's an hour in the studio he was
just visiting is like what are you
working on it's like well this is all
the stuff I'm working on this is a track
I rode and he's like oh my god can we
please have Justin on it
I sent the song to Max Martin and then
he wrote the vocals to it and then we
met Justin in the studio and then he
ended up sounding really awesome on it
so we never tried anybody else I often
times tried 1015 singers on a song and
Justin was the only one on the record
and then we needed somebody for the
bridge and they suggested Niki and I
absolutely love Niki sure did I think
it's awesome I think it was his idea I
don't think I was around to be in it but
I also don't remember if he asked me to
be in it I said don't know what I would
have done in it I mean I love pools and
Swimming's that maybe I would have been
one of those dancers in the pool break3
was a track I made similar story to be
doing a beat it ended up not feeling
like the right song for me but I loved
the song I sent it to next Martin and he
wrote the top line and he then called me
and was like hey I'm in the studio with
this girl called Ariana Grande do you
know her I'm like yes I sure do know her
would you want her to give it a shot I'm
like yes please
so she's saying it sounded obviously
incredible but her voice was way higher
so I had to reproduce the song I think
five semitones higher than it originally
was I'm super thankful honestly for the
experience because I love Ariana I've
always been a big fan and just that I
got the chance to work with her on a
track is is something that means a lot
to me
Stables Alessia Cara basically I was way
overworked and I've played too many
shows and I've made too much music and I
need a little bit of a break for six
weeks I didn't do any music whatsoever
didn't went didn't go into the studio at
all and then I felt refreshed and I was
like I'm ready to make music and I
started making stay
I heard alessia's voice on the radio I
was like wow she's she's really good but
I didn't know her I didn't know anybody
from her team and randomly Nickelodeon
called I was like we would like you and
Alicia basically to do a collage of zet
songs and she would sing one and I was
like yeah perfect so we did this little
collage and that's the first time I ever
met her she happened to be in LA the
next day or a week or something and we
recorded it and then it ended up being I
think quite a big song for both of us so
the middle is a song I meet with gray
and Maren Morris and that song went
through I think 13 vocalists at first it
was really hard to find somebody and
then everybody wanted to sing it some of
the singers on the song where people
I've always wanted to work with and it
was the most heartbreaking thing to say
love you but this is not the perfect
time for us to work on a song together
so we were really close to giving up and
then I heard meirin's
demo and I thought that she was
incredible so I the next possible they
flew to Nashville to record her vocal
and then I flew back and comped the
vocal and finished the song and in
between us trying to find singers we
even had two singers who sang the song
who I loved who then jumped off the song
last second so it was just it was like
giving birth to a child and it just took
forever
so when you remix a song you typically
try to keep the core of it alive while
when you make a song you build the core
with lost Japan it was just a little bit
different cuz usually I take songs and I
try to make a completely new world
around them that's kind of how I
approach it but with lawsuit in Japan
because I love the song love the
original my approach was rather to take
a Shawn Mendes song and put my twist to
it to the point where it's not just as
that song like a remix would usually be
but it's a mix of both of us and it's
what it would have been if we both wrote
the song together
I love the remix I love playing it I
love listening to it it's a different
vibe than I normally make is it's much
more chill and groovy and it's also
definitely different for Shawn but I
feel like this combination just kind of
worked magically together we were
wanting to work together for so long so
this was a really great opportunity and
as I was working on the song I was just
sending him you know ideas and he was
giving me feedback because we weren't in
the same room together so it was it had
to be via phone and then we finished the
song to the point where we both loved it
the way it was
[Music]
two colors is the title track to my
album true colors and I released the
song and then I read about some of the
news about Kesha online and I I just
tweeted her if you need somebody to make
music with her if you need help I'm here
I didn't know she was allowed to make
music or I think she wasn't actually
allowed to make music so at that point I
was approaching it more like a therapy
thing because I know she's a musician
she loves to make music we decided why
don't we rerecord true colors and make
your story out of that so we got in the
studio and we recorded the song and then
dr. Luke's label or whoever was in
charge heard that we were working
together and they said that if it's true
they are going to give us permission to
release it for whatever reason I don't
know that had anything to do with me or
whatever was going on
suddenly were like wait we could
actually maybe release your voice again
so we finished this song and then we got
permission and we released the song in a
time where I think she was in a really
really dark place and I think it felt
really good for everybody to see her
shine again it's time to light the flame
before every
a lot of my fans don't know where I come
from and I come from classical piano and
being a drummer for longer than I've
been a DJ so playing instruments and
making organic music is is where I come
from and I felt like after I had success
more or less overnight if you want to
call it people forgot my past and forgot
that destined this is still a part of my
heart making a statement by making an
album called true colors and showing
people my true colors in the title track
being organic instruments I think was a
was a really important step for me and
ever since I feel like people have
accepted me more as an artist and less
as just a thing and if I now come up
with something new and different people
know that you know this is part of me at
this point I kind of accepted the fact
that my songs will probably be played on
the radio or TV in most places you go
but it still catches you off-guard no
matter how many times I've heard my song
on the radio every time it starts
playing it's still kind of like that's
that's awesome and yeah to be able to
have a song and then everybody maybe
they don't even speak the language and
they still know the words to the song
that's just something really really
magical and and kind of shows you how
music can really bring culture together
and eliminate all barriers that you know
there might be
you